[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal
préparé par la rédaction de tv 78 nous
sommes le mardi 28 septembre voici les
titres de l'actualité locale
le handisport français aura son siège
l'institut en santé parra sport
connectée va ouvrir ses portes en 2024
aux mureaux un grand projet dont il a
été question lors de la troisième
édition du symposium sport santé
organisée par l'université versailles
saint quentin en yvelines le détail à
suivre plus 57,25 % pour le gaz depuis
le début de l'année un bond de 10%
prévue en 2022 pour l'électricité le
prix les factures d'énergie flambe en ce
moment l'une des solutions pour contenir
quelques peu cette hausse la rénovation
énergétique de votre logement on entend
avec séverin horvais de l' agence locale
de l'énergie et du climat de saint
quentin en yvelines et puis la fête des
possibles est revenu à saint quentin en
yvelines pour une sixième édition
c'était samedi dernier le but valoriser
les initiatives locales une vingtaine
d'associations saint-quentinoise étaient
présentes au programme ateliers et
échanges autour de l'écologie
de la danse aussi au programme de ce
journal avec une compétition
internationale de breakdance à poissy le
week-end dernier l engouement monte vous
le verrez à trois ans de l'entrée de la
discipline aux jeux olympiques de paris
mais avant de développer ces types cette
information révélée par nos confrères de
mediapart la vente du domaine de grignon
serait retardé le conte premier qui
avait qui devait être signé
prochainement aurait été repoussée à fin
décembre en cause un article du code de
l'urbanisme qui n'auraient pas été
respectées pour rappel cet été l'état
annonçait vendre le site occupé depuis
de nombreuses années par agro paris tech
et berceau de l'agronomie française au
promoteur immobilier altarea cogedim
une nouvelle qui avait fait bondir
associations élus locaux qui porte leur
propre projet ils s'étaient rassemblés
sur place le 11 septembre dernier et une
nouvelle mobilisation est prévue dans
deux jours sur place
[Musique]
direction à présent montigny le
bretonneux je vous en parlais dans les
titres l'université versailles saint
quentin organisé il ya quelques jours
son 3e symposium sport santé c'était à
l'uni faire alu fr est simone veil lille
ufr des sciences de la santé pour cette
édition 2021 la thématique du handisport
était à l'honneur avec la présence de
sportifs de haut niveau l occasion
également de revenir sur le projet de
l'institut en santé parra sport
connectés en préparation aux mureaux et
nicolas landry et patrick jacques de
dixmude
c'est le projet phare de l'ue fr simone
veil santé de l'ue vs qu l'institut en
santé parra sport connectés qui sera lui
suture aux mureaux cet établissement
prévu pour 2024 sera dédiée au sport et
handicap
d'infrastructures spécialisées sur le
suivi médical la formation des
professionnels de santé et la recherche
et développement technologique
on est sur une dimension technologique
des exosquelettes de l'orthèse de la
prothèse des fauteuils roulants et
également des aides techniques pour
pouvoir pratiquer du sport ainsi qu lui
sera la structure opérationnelle le site
l'endroit le carrefour où physiquement
les gens se rencontreront à la fois les
chercheurs les enseignants les sportifs
et sportives tout venant les sportifs de
haut niveau et donc c'est cette vie en
commun cet échange permanent qui sera
source d'innovation des sportifs de haut
niveau des chercheurs des professionnels
de santé tous sont rassemblés pour le
3ème symposium sport santé de l'ufr
simone veil de l'ue vs qu l'occasion
chaque année d'échangés sur une
thématique cette année c'est le sport et
le handicap le thème du handicap est un
thème
prioritaire est majeur de l'université
et de l'ufr des sciences de la santé
et donc c'est effectivement
un thème dans lequel nouveaux projets
scientifiques sont développés en
particulier l'institut du sport
connectée du professeur françois jeunes
et autres nouveautés présentées lors de
ce symposium la création du département
universitaire de médecine des activités
physiques et sportives
[Musique]
c'est une hausse dont beaucoup de
français se passerait bien les tarifs de
l'énergie ne cessent d'augmenter depuis
plusieurs mois et pour décrypter ce
phénomène michael et demi d'euros est
avec mon plateau d'on soir en soir
journalistes de la rédaction de tv 78 on
va tout de suite parlé et du gaz michael
avec une grosse augmentation c'est une
hausse historique qui attend les
français les tarifs réglementés à du gaz
vont subir une forte hausse après avoir
augmenté de plus de 25% ses trois
derniers mois le tarif réglementé du gaz
va en moyenne augmenté de 12,6 pour cent
toutes taxes comprises ce vendredi 1er
octobre la raison les cours du gaz sont
à des niveaux très élevés en europe en
raison notamment d'une forte demande et
les stockages sont bas et cette hausse
n'est pas prête de s'arrêter devrait
durer pendant encore plusieurs mois et
encore pire il n'y a pas que le gaz
l'électricité aussi augmentent tout à
fait à grégory les prix de l'électricité
sont en train de flamber sur le un
marché à cause notamment de la hausse
des prix du gaz et des quotas d'émission
de co2 cela devrait se traduire par une
forte hausse pour le consommateur au
début de l'année à 2022 mais l'étude
anticipe un bond de près de 10% pour le
tarifs réglementés de vente de
l'électricité toutes taxes comprises ce
qui en reviendrait à une augmentation en
moyenne 250 euros pour les ménages
utilisant de l'électricité comme moyen
de chauffage pour les français qui se
chauffent au fioul ou au bois qu'en est
il là aussi on constate des hausses le
prix à du fioul dépend de l'évolution du
pétrole un moyen national du prix du
fuel et 2 878 euros pour mille litres
des prix qui ont connu une augmentation
en un an de 2 113 euros pour mille
litres le prix montent en flèche
constamment depuis mai dernier cette
hausse concerne 3 4 millions de
logements en france seul le bois de
chauffage n'a pas encore connu de hausse
significative mais il pourrait
y avoir des répercussions après une
hausse de 50% du prix du bois brut
principalement destiné aux chantiers
seulement 5% des ménages se chauffent
avec du bois merci michael pour toutes
ces précisions bonsoir c'est vraiment
rech soit vous êtes coordinateur de la
plateforme repères habitat pour la lex
kyle alex et l' agence locale de
l'énergie et du climat de saint quentin
en yvelines alors avec vous on va parler
de rénovation énergétique et de ce salon
de la rénovation énergétique quatrième
édition qui arrive le 10 octobre ce sera
à noisy le roi je vais pas vous demander
forcément de commenter les chiffres que
l'on vient d'entendre mais ce que l'on
peut dire que la rénovation énergétique
c'est un bon moyen en tout cas un bon
moyen pour commencer à faire baisser le
prix de sa facture l'énergie
complètement complètement donc très très
succinctement pour pallier à la
variation de plus en plus fréquente du
prix de l'énergie on a depuis 2010 est
un plan de rénovation énergétique du
bâtiment qui visant tout
particulièrement l'habitat est donc ce
plan prévoit de rénover notamment
d'isoler donc près de 500 mille
logements par an est ce donc pour faire
baisser les besoins en énergie de chaque
bâtiment ce qui fait que les variations
du coût de chaque combustible un patron
un petit peu moins les factures des
français mais concrètement en étant
moins une passoire énergétique on va
forcément utilisés - l'énergie et donc
la facture va baisser c'est une
conséquence complètement ce qu'on
appelle les passoires énergétiques ça va
être donc toutes les maisons qui vont
être classés f ou g sur les diagnostics
de performance énergétique des documents
légaux qui sont imposés à la vente ou
mises en location de tout bien
immobilier pour améliorer l'étiquette
énergie de vos biens deux options isolé
pour baisser les consommations
énergétiques
puis également il ya une deuxième
étiquette qui est l'étiquette gaz à
effet de serre pour réduire les
émissions c'est de passer des énergies
fossiles comme le gaz ou le fioul à des
énergies renouvelables comme le bois ou
l'électricité verte est ce que les
français alors plus peut être pris plus
précisément on va dire même les
yvelinois les suds yvelinois puisque la
plateforme repères habitat c'est pour le
sud est vide est ce qu'ils se mettent de
plus en plus à ces travaux de rénovation
énergétique complètement là depuis le
début d'année on a traité près de 1300
demandes voilà deux
d'accompagnement techniques
méthodologiques et financier donc sur le
montage de projets de rénovation donc le
service a le vent en poupe ce c'est
assez intéressant pour nous il ya des
aides d'état qui suivent de différents
types d aides publiques et privées y en
a pour tout le monde partout n'est pas
conditionnée par les ressources des
ménages donc vraiment on a une
incitation forte à rénover actuellement
c'est son habitat qu'est ce qui peut
freiner ce que c'est le prix peut-être
de ces travaux vous me disiez tout à
l'heure le prix des matières premières
on sait qu'il ya une crise en ce moment
des matières premières augmentent donc
forcément ça ça se ressent peut-être
aussi sur les factures complètement
alors on a des fringues différents types
en sueur sur ce type de projet
délai ya souvent une problématique de
confiance envers les artisans nous c'est
pour ça que au travers de repères
habitat on propose en annuaire
d'artisans avec lesquels on est en
relation suivie pour des travaux de
qualité en confiance n'a pu y va y avoir
ensuite des problématiques donc de coût
des travaux là les différentes aides
sont là pour pour y palier il ya des
aides qui sont là pour réduire les
restes à charge avec des mécanismes de
primes d'abattements fiscaux cda qui
sont là pour payer les restes à charge
avec différents systèmes de crédit des
crédits attachés à la personne à taux
zéro ou des crédits avec intérêts
attachés au bâtiment est donc là vous
rembourser votre prêt au moment de la
vente du bien sur la plus-value
puisqu'il est aussi important dire aussi
c'est que peut-être que la facture être
élevé mais c'est un investissement sur
le long terme ça va se ressentir la
baisse on le disait tout à l'heure sur
la la facture d'énergie va se ressentir
sur plusieurs années complètement alors
la question des temps de retour sur
investissement est souvent une des
premières questions qu'on va nous nous
nous soulevées notamment du côté des
propriétaires bailleurs alors très
honnêtement quand on s'intéresse à des
projets de rénovation énergétique les
motivations premières sont avant tout le
confort dans le logement notamment pour
les propriétaires occupants ça va être
également donc les problématiques de
d'économies sur les factures
énergétiques
donc là effectivement déçu plutôt sur
des problématiques de gestion de la
trésorerie du ménage et puis ensuite on
a beaucoup de
sensibilité écologique qui vont pousser
certains à vouloir faire des travaux
plutôt l'installation de panneaux
photovoltaïques utilisation de matériaux
écologiques pour isoler sa maison on va
voir ce type de préoccupations au niveau
des temps de retour sur investissement
c'est vraiment plutôt du côté des
bailleurs et puis notamment des sociétés
anonymes ou privés
non unipersonnelle on va avoir ce type
de demande à quel moment doit-on se dire
je dois faire des travaux de rénovation
énergétique
il peut y avoir plusieurs moments
le principal déclencheur c'est avant
tout en tout cas pour tout ce qui touche
aux équipements les pannes donc voila
quand votre chaudière fuel arrive en fin
de vie va se poser la question de son
remplacement d'ici 2022 vous n'aurez
plus légalement le droit de remplacer
votre chaudière que le parrain une
hausse de 10 à flou donc se pose
également la question éventuellement
dans
un combustible de chauffage alternatif
l'autre l'autre motivateur pour pour
engager des projets de travaux ça va
être souvent les problématiques de
confort l'arrivée d'un nouveau nouveau
venu dans la famille qui oblige à
aménager les combles ou ce genre de
choses là les problématiques de confort
ce se révèle souvent à ces occasions
dans le dernière chose pour se lancer
justement dans ces travaux de rénovation
énergétique si on habite dans le sud
yves il n'ya la plateforme repères
haditha pour cette rénovation
énergétique je disais avant sud yvelines
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir y faire
concrètement grâce à cette plateforme
excellente question donc nous au sein de
l'als exquis donc c'est une association
d'utilité publique qui porte notamment
la mission de service public faire ses
missions de service public au travers de
laquelle on va comme je disais à
proposer du conseil techniques
méthodologiques et financier sur vos
projets de rénovation vous allez
également donc avoir repéré habitat qui
permet un peu de dépasser cet
accompagnement avec la la mise à
disposition d'un conseiller
individuels entre guillemets qui va
suivre votre dossier tout au long tout
au long de ces différents échanges
plutôt qu'un système de permanence
retour expliqué à chaque fois vous avez
à disposition également via ce service
un annuaire d'artisans avec lesquels on
est en relation de suivi et puis voilà
ça va être la principale plus value de
service nous ce qu'on propose également
pour dépasser donc aussi tout ce qui
touche à un petit peu à la à l'accès aux
services numériques ça va être au
travers notamment de la rénovation
énergétique depuis proposé
l'accompagnement qu'on propose via cette
plateforme en ligne physiquement voilà
fait la transition n'a dépassé mais on
va juste présenter cet événement ce soir
a lieu le 10 octobre c'est la quatrième
édition de ce salon de la rénovation
énergétique ça se passera à la salle des
anciennes écuries à noisy le roi et
concrètement sur place on va retrouver
en présentiel cette plateforme repères
habitat c'est ça complètement donc le 10
octobre est invité un c'est très
accessible depuis la mairie de noisy le
roi
ce sera sur entrée gratuite avec
possibilité se restaurer sur place donc
le salon le concept c'est que quand vous
arrivez vous allez pouvoir rencontrer
toutes les structures du service public
qui vont travailler autour des questions
d'habitat donc voilà on va on va
retrouver le cae qui produit du conseil
sur les aspects
architecturaux d'urbanisme notamment la
deal qui donc là sont plutôt des
juristes qui vont pouvoir vous
renseigner sur tous vos droits par
rapport au logement vous allez retrouver
maisons paysannes de france qui est là
plutôt spécialisés sur l'entretien du
bâti ancien si tu aimais tri qui se
dédie à l'accompagnement des ménages les
plus modestes dans leurs projets de
rénovation globale puis nous donc alex
qui voilà qui est qu'ils vont apporter
les conseils qu'on n'a pas
habituellement puis ensuite vous avez
également un espace avec uniquement des
particuliers qu'ont déjà été au bout de
leur projet de rénovation pour des
échanges violents autour d'expériences
complètement et puis vous aurez à
l'étagé inférieur du coup tous les
professionnels de la plateforme qui
seront là pour répondre à vos questions
et ça aura lieu le 10 octobre à noisy le
roi on retrouve tout le programme sur le
site de l'alec saint quentin en yvelines
qui va s'afficher ça y va s'afficher en
bas de l'écran il y aura plusieurs
choses au programme et notamment la
remise du trophée de la maison économe
c'est déjà la 19e édition dans l'âge et
j'ai pu vivre la réunion voilà donc
vacant on est sur l'ongle concours la
maison économe vous allez
voilà pouvoir voir différentes
réalisations qui ont été faites sur le
territoire est en construction neuve et
en rénovation et donc vous aurez un
lauréat pour chacune de ces catégories
qui repartira avec un vélo électrique
pour les années suivantes n'hésitez pas
si vous avez entrepris des travaux à
vous y inscrire ça peut être l'occasion
de valoriser vos réalisations et puis
plus largement de pouvoir échanger sur
les difficultés ou les bons plans que
vous avez éventuellement trouver sur
votre part du message est passé merci
beaucoup c'est vrai en ré d'avoir été
avec nous et je rappelle vous êtes le
coordinateur de la plateforme repères
habitat pour rénovation énergétique dans
le sud yvelines justement au sujet de la
rénovation énergétique l' agence locale
de l'énergie et du climat de saint
quentin en yvelines a signé la semaine
dernière un partenariat avec des
professionnels de l'immobilier du
territoire le nom de ce projet c'est le
projet actimos les détails dans ce sujet
de mélanie poké
elle la rénovation énergétique ne
concerne pas que les acheteurs et les
vendeurs cette professionnelle sur saint
quentin en yvelines ont signé jeudi 23
septembre actimos un programme
d'accompagnement des acteurs de
l'immobilier qui a une une réforme du
dpe au 1er juillet 2021 donc du coup de
nouvelles normes de calcul un nouveau
document qui est édité et d
les clients se posent des questions de
savoir quelles sont les implications
donc on peut leur expliquer ce qui se
passe dans la réglementation on se
confronte de plus en plus à des gens qui
justement sont surtout ski évolution
énergétique et nous en tant que bons
qu'on n'a pas forcément les solutions
entre nos mains et se rapprocher d'un
partenaire local qui est avec les sky du
coup c'est toujours intéressant une
signature réalisé avec l' agence locale
de l'énergie et du climat de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lauréate
depuis février 2020 de ce projet porté
par leclerc réseau pour la transition
énergétique d'avoir ces professionnels
finalement du logement de l'habitat qui
s'engagent à nos côtés ça nous permet de
toucher un public peut-être un peu plus
large et puis surtout de prodiguer des
conseils en amont avant même de passer à
une phase qui est plutôt des phases de
travaux de réhabilitation là on agit en
amont sur la question de la transition
énergétique le programme sera accompagné
de formation et de sensibilisation pour
tous les signataires de nombreuses aides
à la rénovation sont disponibles ma
prime rénove habiter mieux série n'était
ou encore éco prêt
[Musique]
une vingtaine d'associations réunies
devant la médiathèque du canal à
montigny le bretonneux samedi c'était la
fête des possibles à saint quentin en
yvelines seulement six jours après le
world cleanapp des les yvelines ont pu
être sensibilisés aux enjeux
environnementaux le reportage d'antoine
durand et de julien leroy ce samedi à
montigny le bretonneux se déroulait la
sixième édition de la journée des
possibles devant la médiathèque organisé
par une vingtaine d'associations locales
l'objectif était de sensibiliser aux
enjeux environnementaux
elle est importante parce que il ya
encore des personnes qui ne savent pas
ce que c'est qu'une amap
il ya des gens qui ne connaissent pas
encore le commerce équitable
donc on fait un travail de
sensibilisation
d'information
et on essaie de le faire de façon
ludique au programme de la journée la
présentation des actions locales des
ateliers de sensibilisation ainsi que
des jeux pour les petits et les plus
grands et même si on est bon on peut
ouvrir - les enfants ça va comme
pourtant jusqu'à 77 ans
[Musique]
mais j'ai appris qu'elle graines
importées nakheel plantes j'ai appris à
peu près quelles plantes
conséquent en ce moment à l'épaule
poires
salades je crois ce qui est important
c'est de montrer tout ce qui se passe au
niveau associatif et qui concerne la
préservation de l'environnement feytiat
et quand même pas mal de dassault sur
l'agglo et finalement moi en tant que
membre du national et connaissait les
connaissez pas tout et c'est pour ça que
je suis venu pour voir un peu ce que
font les autres prochain événement
organisé sous la bannière de la fête des
possibles le 29 septembre à l'ermitage
de versailles pour une soirée ciné
partage
le sport et cette mauvaise nouvelle pour
les amateurs de cyclisme sur piste lui
c'est ytrac champion's league ne passera
pas par le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à la deuxième
étape de cette nouvelle compétition
lancée par l'union cycliste
internationale devaient s'y dérouler le
20 novembre prochain mais l'enceinte
continue d'être utilisée comme
vaccinodromes contre le colis de 19 pas
de panique la ligue des champions doit
bien à revenir dès l'an prochain sur
place cette saison la manche est donc
annulée n'est pas remplacé dans le
calendrier il y aura cinq étapes
seulement en espagne lituanie angleterre
et israël est dans trois ans les jeux
olympiques se dérouleront à paris avec
une nouvelle discipline c'est le
breakdance en attendant l'engouement
monte dans le pays spécialiste de cette
danse entre art et sport au travers de
show et pour la troisième fois l'
ultimate battle master accueillait
débreaker du monde entier à la
compétition s'est déroulée le week-end
dernier à poissy retour avec bixente
mayence insisté ban et juniors
[Musique]
ferait de gala opposera marnand peugeot
à poissy ultimate battle masters c'est
l'une des compétitions émergentes du
breakdance cette année c'est une équipe
française qui a remporté le titre
c'était assez rude parce que c'était sûr
du temps lui minutes 10 minutes 10
minutes c'est ça demande beaucoup de
temps beaucoup d'énergie surtout que
on n'était pas préparé à ça mais
on a su quand même
bien bien relever la pente et
on a pu gagner cette compétition et on
est très fier de moi et mon équipe une
belle performance dans le niveau était
élevé avec des équipes venues du monde
entier parce qu'on a pu voir ce soir ça
fait partie de l'excellence mondiale
que ce soit le continent européen le
continent africain le continent
américain voilà ils étaient tous
représentés c'est actuellement ce qui se
fait quasiment de mieux pour encadrer
les athlètes un jury de prestige jury
que j'ai choisi sévèrement à la crème au
niveau de hauts niveaux de débits bois
et français on n'a eu qu'à lille qui est
champion de france on a eu l'idée est
qu'il est triple champion du monde et on
a eu chaud saute une figure emblématique
du boeing français et qui est aussi
champion de france donc on a et vice
champion du monde
du côté des moins de 16 ans l'italien
bboy dunger a gagné la finale face au
français le qui je suis un peu déçu
d'avoir perdu en finale mais là je vais
m'entraîner pour gagner la prochaine
fois peut-être le break dance et ont
désormais une discipline olympique l'
ultimate battle master souhaite
s'inscrire dans les tournois
préparatoires en vue de paris 2024
et pour terminer de la musique avec le
nouveau clip et morceaux de kirtas après
les succès est de trappes et d'omar sy
le rappeur de montigny le bretonneux
revient avec artistes sky un titre
d'environ 4 minutes où il a voulu mettre
en valeur plusieurs talents de saint
quentin en yvelines dans différents
domaines et discipline l'idée de ce
morceau lui est venue du compte
instagram du même nom dédié aux artistes
saint quentinois curtat qui sera en
concert le 4 décembre à la salle
jacques-brel de montigny le bretonneux
et le journal se referme d'ailleurs sur
un extrait d'artistes sky merci de nous
avoir suivis belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]
artiste
on veut faire entendre comme pour moteur
des jaloux des promoteurs des envieux
des imposteurs artix ferait partie
[Musique]
artiste en partie
à petit fort et talentueux très l'assaut
dans la de mieux artie shaw qui met le
feu dans ces flocons aller
[Musique]